salut tout le monde j'ai trouvé un
nouvel appart et pour vous montrer
comment ça se passe un bon déménagement
il me suis dit pourquoi pas filmer
la danse qu'elle a en direct
sabre à cannes ce soir au salon auquel
manger mieux les gars c'est de démonter
vos meubles pas pour moi un club assez
logique c'est la base des managers
gagnent moins était monté la chine va
voir qui sera convoquée dans mon tennis
allô bonjour en tenez votre conseiller
edf je vous confirme la souscription de
votre contrat d'énergie pour votre
nouvel appartement est ce que je pouvais
être utile pour notre show web pour
l'instant je pense qu'on n'aura pas
besoin mais merci quand même monsieur
est parfait et bien sinon vous avez
toujours la check list sur cech
déménagement d'edf qui vous permet de
penser à relever le compteur à souscrire
l'assurance habitation à 4 à wes est
vrai l'assurance habitation et le
compteur à j'avais zappé va écouter soit
heures c'est que j'ai votre numéro si
j'ai besoin je vous rappelle merci
beaucoup monsieur merci les gars petite
astuce pour les vêtements utiliser des
sacs poubelles c'est plus solide et
c'est réutilisables pour vous devrez ça
au foot et les vêtements l'intérieur et
garder les cartons pour les trucs lourd
et fragile alors ça c'est fait on passe
à la suite de check list à cowes ouais
tu es vernet des cartons je vais février
en cours au chaos ou comme quoi la table
elle est encore là est empli les cartons
en germant démonter la femme qu'il faut
l'arroser varney des cartons s'il te
plaît ok ok
est là pour m'aider ou pas les gars vous
vous souvenez des cartons regardez ce
qu'il a fait regardez bien regarder eh
ben on regarde papa c'est quoi sa phase
regarde regarde
mon portefeuille va au supermarché les
regarde s'ils ont des cartes ont bâti et
tu prends un truc à manger au passage à
alma qu il parle ça fait loin de saint
froult toujours faire attention les
objets de valeur faut les protéger ultra
fragile on est bien
ils ont plus de cartons certes et
ménagement c'est un cauchemar c'est
galère
patricot pizza pizza mais on n'a pas de
four à micro ondes
allô oui c'est le gars de du
déménagement on s'appelait tout à
l'heure
non y'a rien qui vaille a rien qui va
les cartons sont trempés on les a
laissés dans la cour on est en galère on
n'a pas de carte ou
comme cette cliente et vous avez même
des réductions sur les cartons ah bon
c'est possible on va faire ça oui il en
faut combien franchement ça passe mais
atteint les phonies et laisse-moi légal
agaléga c'est commencer comment regarder
de trouver quoi les cartons ils sont là
à l'écart pose alors est gérée où j'ai
passé les scandales tard à manger assis
toi si toi alors qu'est-ce qu'on a
caisse commune j'ai pensé pital éclater
la pizza attends attends attends à gré
avec je mange quoi
[Musique]
manger la pizza et après on va faire les
cartons mais moi je m'en serais très
vite
y a rien rien qu'est ce qui se passe tu
paies un avc ou quoi j'ai un mauvais
pressentiment pour lequel lendemain
pourquoi bruxelles hainard tu le connais
bien je le connais c'est un problème ah
ben on va s'adapter
[Musique]